Just as we learned very early in this course,
I think in lesson three, structure is function. Not
only for proteins in our cells, but also in
the world of pharmacology. Remember that drugs bind to
proteins in your cells and in your body. And
if a protein has even a slight change in
its conformation or structure, it will likely change its
ability to interact with the drug, or the speed with
which it can interact with the drug. Structural variation
in pharmacodynamic proteins affects the target effects of the
drug. For example, the drug here in red binds
the receptor here in this Y-shaped conformation. When it binds,
there's a normal activity that happens, a target effect
if you will. But if we have a variation in
the structure of this receptor, now the drug can't
bind to it in the same way, so the activity
turns out to be reduced. A genetic variation that altered the structure of the
protein resulted in a functional change for
the drug. Structural variation in pharmacokinetic proteins affects
the speed with which a drug is metabolized, or broken down. In this case the
drug is in red, being metabolized by
the purple protein, into these two smaller metabolites.
This would be our normal drug metabolism. But we
could have a variant over here that changed the structure
of the enzyme that breaks down the drug. And
now, there's a reduced activity or no drug metabolism at
all. Let's see if you can pull in the
information we've learned about up to this point in the
lesson. What do you think would result from a
structural change of the GABA receptor, causing an increase in
the pharmacodynamic efficiency to bind alcohol?
And a structural change of alcohol
dehydrogenase, or ADH, causing a decrease
in pharmacokinetic efficiency of alcohol metabolism?
Would you expect extreme intoxication, moderate
intoxication, or minimal intoxication? Remember, this
time we're combining what we know
about the pharmacodynamic, and the pharmacokinetic pathways,
at one time, to see the overall effect of
the drug on your whole system, or your body.